welcome to architecting with google
cloud i'm developer advocate caslin
fields and today we're going to explore
developer workspaces with itopia to walk
us through it today we have jan van
bruggen would you introduce yourself jan
sure hi my name is yan i am developer
relations at itopia and my job is to
make sure that the developer experience
that we've been making for you over the
last year is top notch
awesome so let's start off by learning a
little bit more about itopia could you
tell us a little bit about the company
so itopia is all about remote work
hybrid work whatever you want to call it
either way we're trying to make it
easier and more secure for you to use
the apps that you need in your daily
work by putting them in a web browser
and the specific product we're going to
be talking about today could you tell us
a little bit about that we call it
itopia spaces and these spaces are
workspaces for developers to code inside
of so ide in a browser basically
is definitely an area that i've heard a
lot of interest in especially over the
years
a lot of folks are interested in this
idea of development environments in
browsers i think so let's start off
talking about the user perspective could
you tell me a little about the user
journey of how one would get started
using this product and what that would
look like so developers
may or may not have tried ides in a
browser before may have tried things
like cloud 9 or code server
there's a couple of different projects
that have been popping up over the last
year we're trying to you know package
all that up into a one-stop shop for you
and also to build on top of it so that
you don't need to choose just one ide
or have to configure the lower level
stuff manually we try to smooth all that
out for you so that it's really just as
easy as
your admin for your team saying hey
here's a link you pop open the link open
it up in a web browser and it's an ide
and you just start coding on the next
you know issue that you have in your
issue tracker
and work on it push it up to git and
call it a day no need to get cloned
locally no need to install and do
package management locally
all of that overhead is
you know essentially swept away it
sounds a bit magical so
if someone wanted to get started and try
this out
it's on google marketplace right yes
it's on google cloud marketplace uh you
can try out the free trial there
see the ides that we support try
bringing in one of your own and confirm
that it really is just you know the
things that you're doing locally you do
around a web browser instead
so i really see this as a solution to a
problem and that problem being local
development environments on laptops
could you tell me a bit more about that
problem and the types of challenges that
you see this solution trying to solve so
there's a lot to love about you know
every developer having their own laptop
you can guarantee you know
responsiveness you know good hardware
give them all macbooks let them all have
you know complete control over their
environment install what they need but
you run into some problems some of them
are around security risks of saying like
hey let's get clone our entire code base
that developers at one point had access
to onto all of these hard drives that
we've shipped around the globe and then
recover them later when employees leave
the company hopefully we recover them
and hopefully nothing happens to them
hopefully they don't get lost hopefully
they didn't install the wrong
third-party software hopefully they
didn't visit the wrong website there's a
lot of hopefullys in there and you can
do some things to mitigate those risks
you can monitor the laptops and you can
put different controls on them but at
the end of the day the problem is going
to exist if you're having hardware that
you're doing work on
so
that's part of the problem another part
of it is
you can
have like a 25-step onboarding guide for
your team for how to set up your
environment and then everyone can just
update and maintain those environments
but inevitably people are going to drift
from each other you're going to have one
person on ubuntu 18 or 20 mac os 12 or
13 windows 10 or 11
and then on top of the operating systems
you've got different package managers to
install different versions of these
underlying operating system dependencies
and then hopefully you are using
something like npm to do npm install or
pip to do pip install so you really
can't guarantee that these environments
are going to match you're going to have
these quirks you're going to have these
unique little
problems that each developer is going to
have to solve on their own
so what you'll end up with is all of
these environments that don't quite
match to each other and you could push
that problem onto your developers or you
could provide them with something like a
config file maybe even a docker file to
specify all of these dependencies that
they need and you can containerize this
environment to make it more reproducible
to make it hermetically sealed against
these changes
it's a little bit hard to use that it's
a little bit hard to get your guise
inside that and how to get your
aesthetic personalizations on top of it
but that same idea of what if we could
containerize and that same idea of what
if we could virtualize off of these
laptops are basically the backbone of
why we think itopiaspaces is special
you're putting it in a web browser so
that you can run it from a chromebook
you can run it from a macbook windows
any operating system that can run a web
browser so you don't need high powered
hardware in order to run the unit tests
or just do text editing which is a
little bit silly in this day and age and
also you can have that standardization
and that customization for your team so
that when new people are coming onto the
team they don't need to wait two weeks
for a laptop they don't need to spend
two more weeks configuring it as someone
who is deep in the container space this
it works on my machine problem is
something that's been a big theme in my
life for the last several years and i'm
excited to hear about the way that this
solution is trying to address that could
you talk a little bit about how it
relates to docker and this it works on
my machine problem so i've been using
docker for a while now i love using it
to you know lock down my local
configuration and not have that drift to
be able to guarantee that when i set up
my system one day i don't need to set it
up again every day after that it's
really nice that ides like vs code
support running inside of a docker
container and then you can have the gui
outside of it but all of the backbones
and the internals inside of it we're
really standing on the shoulders of
those giants with this service by
putting them in the browser we are you
know detaching you from the system that
it's running on but we're giving you
that control over what's installed there
so we're running on top of google
kubernetes engine and kubernetes and
we're actually running on top of this
open source platform called selkies so
if anyone wants to check out the
platform for how we're doing these per
user sessions and how we're defining
them check it out on github
it's pretty cool it was invented inside
of google and then it's been brought
outside into the open source world
everything that we do on top of you know
virtualization and containerization is
really powered by that so if you want to
check it out that's a a really powerful
tool for a variety of things not just
for ides but for you know video game
streaming or if you wanted to do 3d
graphics editing or animation if you
want to have the persistence of having a
stateful
user session in kubernetes this
automates a lot of that for you
so selkie's the open source project is
for
user sessions and creating user sessions
usually using kubernetes is that a good
way to describe it uh it's essentially
if you're going to have you know any
sort of sso where you get access to a
remote session or a remote server and
you're going to want to make sure that
you don't just get a different ip
address every single time that you're
popping in there to have that stateful
session and also to be able to stream
what you need out of that pod selkies is
going to help out a lot with that
it's really nice that the solution is
built on an open source solution so
people can go check out how it works and
actually contribute to it if they see
something that they need or they have
some other use case where they think
that functionality might be useful
i also want to dive a little bit deeper
into the google cloud components of this
architecture you mentioned gke what
other components of google cloud are you
all using and how do they fit into the
architecture of how you actually deliver
this service
right so the end user experience really
you have no idea that you're running on
tip for kubernetes you don't know that
it's even running on google kubernetes
engine uh all you need to know is that
when you connect to the space you
connect to the space but what's
happening under the hood is that we are
automating and orchestrating the setup
of these kubernetes clusters you know
the provisioning of new custom resources
with a control plane that exposes a
really lightweight graphql api and
that's all running on top of cloud run
we really like cloudrun for its
serverless ability
how well it scales how lightweight it is
for us to maintain and then those cloud
run microservices are controlling the
gke clusters and telling them what to do
so that we don't need to be in there
with wrenches on the daily configuring
custom resources
what i think is really cool about this
architecture is basically you're
providing this managed kind of
serverless in a sense managed service to
your users that is built on top of these
managed services in google cloud like
gke and cloud run so from a user's
perspective there might as well not be
servers you're just using the provided
service
but then underneath you're actually
using gke and cloudrun to accomplish
that so can you talk a little bit more
about how gke and cloudrun fit into
the architecture and the control plane
that you were talking about
sure so we think that kubernetes is a
really powerful engine for providing end
user services for providing you know the
backbone of what your company is going
to be shipping
and that's why we use it we think that
it has really powerful networking
controls so that we can provide vpc
peering so that we can provide firewall
configuration for what your actual
spaces are you know what packets are
going in and out of them you want to be
able to control that as an enterprise
and kubernetes gives us that level of
you know fine-grained control and
fine-grained access permissions so that
you know that only the people that
you're providing access to are getting
acled into the right pods
but
when we're actually packaging all that
up and getting it out the door we don't
need kubernetes for that we don't need
kubernetes to do you know our devops
work we don't need kubernetes to do our
api server and so instead we just throw
all that in cloud run it's lighter
weight it's easier for us to
administrate and in general it just has
less overhead both financially and
developer
you know administratively
awesome
and one thing i want to ask is
i'm sure this pattern of running a
managed service using google cloud
services is a pretty common one what
kinds of advice would you have for
anyone who's trying to run a service on
top of something like cloud run and gke
sure i would say don't make the same
mistake we did which is splitting up
into a million microservices from day
one
we got really excited about cloud run we
were like oh we could have microservice
that does this microservice that does
this and you've probably heard it a lot
of times by now if you are in the
microservice space but uh you can split
them up a little bit later you can start
with something a little bit more you
know self-contained uh we ended up
having more connections and interactions
between cloud run microservices than i
think we needed
but we got there eventually it just took
us a little bit longer than if we'd
started with a monolithic cloud run
service and broken it up as necessary as
we went along
that's such an interesting journey
because we're always talking about
convert to microservices and
microservices are great you can use them
with containers they're cloud native
um but it's interesting to see the
opposite angle here kind of of when you
have
microservices that are true too prolific
to begin with you don't really have the
excuse to start learning the tools
a little bit slower which you do with
the monolith i guess yeah we just got a
little too excited as developers can get
we saw a shiny new toy that we could
build our architecture on top of and we
wanted to use every little bit of
feature set that it had so in hindsight
we went a little bit overboard but hey
that's how you learn
we've learned a lot of things you know i
feel like that happens with developers a
lot where you get really excited about
adopting a new technology and you go a
little bit overboard on it i kind of did
that with you know running docker
locally and having docker desktop be
running every single one of my dev
projects i had a docker file for this
project a dockerfile for this project
and anytime that i needed to do like a
docker desktop update or maybe get a
subscription for it i was suddenly like
locked into this weird ecosystem that
wasn't fully fleshed out
so the year of the docker desktop never
really manifested for development
environments i feel like
kind of in the same way that it's nice
to run someone else's managed service
built on linux here with itopia spaces
you can run on top of someone else's
managed service that's built with docker
and kubernetes so yeah you can have that
containerization and you can have the
level of you know personalization on top
with your team's config layers and then
the operating system updates managed by
us but you don't need to be on the hook
to maintain all of the things that you
made in one excited afternoon for your
team
and if people want to try out the
solution how can people learn more about
itopia and also sulky's the open source
project that you mentioned
yeah so if you want to try out our ide
in a browser dip your toes in a little
bit go to
itopiaspaces.com and you can sign up for
the free trial through the google cloud
marketplace as well
for selkies that's all open source on
github so if you want to check out the
selkies organization and repos i'll link
them in the dooblydoo somehow in this
video
thank you so much yan i learned a lot
today about developer workspaces with
itopia
thanks for having me caslin and if you
want to check out any of those links
that we mentioned in the video today be
sure to check out the description below
and be sure to like and subscribe to get
more videos from architecting with
google cloud
[Music]
you